beacon press is proud and honored to be
the publishers of the book we are here
tonight to celebrate Sara's long walk by
Stephen Kendrick and Paul Kendrick in
1847 right here on Beacon Hill right
past this church in fact a five year old
girl named Sarah Roberts walked past
five white schools in order to attend
the densely crowded Black abl Smith
school her father was so incensed that
his daughter had to be turned away at
these white schools that he decided to
sue the city of Boston on her behalf he
turned to a very young 24 year old
Robert Morris the first black attorney
to ever win a jury case in America
together with Charles Sumner I also a
young man and a Brahmin this legal team
forged a powerful argument against
school segregation that has reverberate
adown through American history in a
direct line to Brown versus Board of
Education today if you have heard of the
Roberts case it's a footnote in most
history books they haven't heard of
little Sarah Roberts or of the 3,000
free blacks in Boston who fought
valiantly for not only school
desegregation but to desegregate
theaters and railway cars to legalize
interracial marriage and to form the
first black army regiment but now in
Sarah's long walk
Stephen Kendrick and Paul Kendrick are
telling their inspiring story of this
remarkable community of which this
little girl and her father were apart
and bringing to light this very human
side of a crucial struggle Stephen
Kendrick is the author of two previous
books a novel Night Watch and a
nonfiction work wholly Clues the Gospel
according to Sherlock Holmes
he's the minister of first and second
church here in Boston his son Paul
Kendrick worked as a director of the
grassroots campaign for the Democratic
National Committee during the
presidential election of 2004 he is
presidential arts scholar and a senior
at George Washington University in
Washington DC where he also serves as
n-double-a-cp chapter president please
join me in welcoming them to the podium
tonight
this reminds me a peer DeVries once said
you loved everything about writing
except the paperwork but here we are
where it's so glad to be here tonight we
want to thank all of you all of you for
braving the snow the sleet the charming
and pissed rest whether that makes
Boston the place that it is we want to
thank all those people made this evening
possible and particularly join Wyckoff
who's been a superb editor and we
appreciate everything everything that
you've done for us we also want to thank
beacon press because they believed in
this book and they believed in the story
that Sara's story and the story of this
free black community needed to be told
we moved here some years ago I remember
one evening walking down to hear a
speech by Bernadette Williams and also
you Horace who is here in the audience
tonight
you were doing a presentation about how
activism can be restart and
reinvigorated and it was in the African
meeting house which is just around the
corner from us it's now in under
renovations but please someday go and
sit and feel the vibrations in that room
and that's what Horace did and
Bernadette sheep helped all of us in the
room that night understand how important
it is to understand our task our life
task in our era in our time over the
crest and then down Joy Street any
winter night you can come and see what
Beacon Hill is really like it takes no
effort whatsoever to understand and to
feel what it was like in Antebellum
Boston reflecting in the shining brick
sidewalks the rows of the glazed street
lights glowing flickering yellow gasping
this is a place where nearly 3,000 free
blacks lived on the North Slope of
Beacon Hill the steep descent increases
once you walk past the infamous cross
street
me long ago designed to effectively
separate the white elite sided Beacon
Hill from the North Slope where the poor
servants and the trades people lived
later will walk up the street towards
beacon press will pass the African
meeting house will pass the Smith School
which is today the Museum of
african-american history will be very
near the home of Lewis Hayden a black
activist born a slave in Kentucky who
stood on the porch of his home and said
if you come any further and try to take
the fugitive slaves who are in this home
I will dynamite this house right in
front of you and we're gonna go past the
home of William C now a young boy who
was refused to the Franklin medal
although he earned it
and he kept alive this boycott of the
Smith school for 15 years will pass his
home in his spirit in the home of Robert
Roberts the father of Benjamin Roberts
who became a printer and Benjamin and
Adelines
daughter Sarah their echoes their
courage and their bravery are with us
tonight
Bernadette Williams the Ranger that
night stood and told us about the
Roberts case right here on Beacon Hill
she said one father and a lawyer named
Robert Morris helped to change American
history and so she did and descendants
of the Robert's family live here in
Boston today and and we want to
encourage them to tell the full story
which we do not do but to tell the full
story of their family's long and brave
history but we want to thank them and
applause thank you for being here
tonight
great tidal movements of history that
change our lives and change the current
of our society sometimes come from very
small incidents that are little noticed
at the time but later are seen as
somehow a pivot point of history Paul
and I were excited to find one story
that helped to illuminate something that
has changed all of our lives America was
changed by this suit called Roberts
versus the City of Boston and it's also
a way to get into a fascinating story of
how white and black lived in a very
small neighborhood more than 150 years
ago this small geographical place called
Beacon Hill about 10 blocks by 10
contained within its boundaries two
worlds one poor and black and the other
white and wealthy and yet as separate as
these worlds seemed
each contained within itself certain
brave individuals who decided to cross
the line of pickney streets to work
together the story of Sarah's long walk
maybe not a particularly sentimental one
or even a comfortable story but it is I
believe a very inspirational story it's
one that we need to pay attention to and
it's very difficult to envision just how
powerful the forces of racism really
were for that generation of baktun
Boston blacks and activists and even how
it affected their abolitionist allies
this struggle concerns how an
essentially white abolitionist movement
was transformed into a black LED and
black inspired protest movement
inspiring nothing so much as the civil
rights revolution of the early 1960s
this is the story of civil rights born
in the age of abolitionism now Boston
was then and I suggest tonight still is
a city where its people are if not
strictly segregated at least
segmented in powerful ways the high
ideals an imposing saga of liberty that
are the city's natural legacy remain
quite real and Noble but so does the
painful struggle across far too many
generations to achieve any kind of
sensible and humane return 'ti between
white and black working together and I
will now turn this over to Paul
my co-author I'm going to read a passage
from the book when Benjamin Roberts took
a turn towards the Cates that would
eventually change America as Steven
mentioned Benjamin Franklin Roberts was
a free black printer and he had been
forced to walk past white schools on the
way to his segregated school is a child
and this picks up as his daughter is
having to do the same when Sarah turned
form in April 1847 [ __ ] even applied to
the primary school committee for Sarah's
admission to the school closest to their
house they lived not on Beacon Hill near
the Smith School but closer to the docks
in the North End where cold winds blew
in from the harbor and swirled through
narrow streets to get to the Smith
School it was a steep walk up Beacon
Hill along Belknap Street to the school
and despite the exertion this walk
demanded the four-year-olds ticket of
admission to her nearest school was
declined
Roberts stubbornly chose to defy the
mandate of the school board he resolved
to take Sarah to the closest white
school and enroll her directly at the
oldest school surprisingly Sarah was
accepted it's unclear how Roberts was
able to gain admission to the school
since the school committee had been
unambiguous in their prohibitions
against integration but perhaps he'd
found a sympathetic principal
willing to ignore the stated rules
perhaps Roberts had been lucky enough
just to find a school unaware of the
rule of segregation of Boston but this
seems unlikely nonetheless little sara
was doing what no black child had done
in almost a half a century in Boston
learned with white pupils fortunately
the state of affairs was not to last
although it took several months the
school committee finally got wind of
this unusual situation and would not let
Sarah's defiant father disrupt their
carefully preserved system of school
segregation school committee saw to it
that the four-year-old Sarah was removed
from her new school by a police officer
the emotional damage a four-year-old
might suffer from being forcibly taken
from her classroom by a policeman for
reasons she most likely did not
understand it's difficult to imagine
it's painful to pause and feel the true
human cost the shock and the shame of
that moment no matter how many pages are
ultimately written about the case the
hard truth is in that day and this
traumatic event might have settled the
issue for a man of lesser determination
than midshipman Roberts but instead of
sitting Sarah on to the Smith school he
changed his course in a dramatic and
fateful way he decided to seek out the
young black lawyer who had become the
talk of the black community after
defeating a white lawyer in court so
let's pause for a second to talk about
that lawyer Robert Morris it's kind of
the narrative linchpin of our of our
work Robert Morris is grandson of a
slave son of a waiter in Salem
Massachusetts there's some serendipitous
circumstances he ends up being the
servant of a white abolitionist lawyer
in Boston named Ellis grey Laurie
and Lauren had a illegal parentis at the
time
young white legal apprentice and this
kid was just not keeping up with his
duties he he was lazy he didn't really
contribute anything to Lauren his office
and Lauren started to notice that Robert
Morris who was supposed to be the
servant was doing everything that needed
to be done by a legal apprentice and so
he says to him do you want to be trained
as a lawyer and Morris says yes so
Lauren trains this this young black kid
and he grows into a man that when he
goes into his first case he went to the
opposing counsels office a few days
before the case was going to be held and
the opposing counsel wouldn't even offer
him a seat in his office and he said are
you gonna try this case and Moore says
yes I am
and he says while I'm gonna give you the
devil but Morris walks into that
courtroom the next way today a courtroom
that was filled with the black community
would come out to see the first black
lawyer in America try a case and he wins
that case and so when Benjamin Roberts
comes to see him talk about this case
affecting his young daughter
Morris hasn't just become a pretty
seasoned lawyer at age 24 but he's
become a community activist a leader in
the community now before the school
struggle was launched there had already
won two struggles they had fought
against an interracial marriage ban it's
interesting to note that Boston is still
dealing with the issues of who can marry
and they had fought against
transportation segregation on
transportation on the trains and it's
interesting to note that in this and
that struggle Morris had participated in
what were essentially sit-ins folks like
him and Frederick Douglas were thrown
off these trains because they refused to
leave and economic boycotts so the same
kind of tactics we associated with the
1960s civil rights movement they're
using and they won both of these fights
in the early 1840s so they're learning
that this community is learning the
tactics that they're going to use as
they attack school segregation
now this wasn't a done deal that
everyone was on board to school set
school integration we have to think
about the context of these times this
would the Smith School was a strong
community institution and these folks
are talking about sending their kids
into what were unbelievably racist
Boston schools so this was not a done
deal and at one point this community
comes to the point of violence over this
question integrationists were having a
meeting in a church in the African
meeting house and the windows are broken
by the rocks that are coming in people
are ducking under the pews this was an
issue of ideologies that held a lot of
passion but they boycott the school and
the first day of school in 18-49 the
activists led by Morris and Nell
standing hand in hand not letting
children go into that school and that
the context that this case emerges in
and not to mention the context of a
community is impoverished that is up
against unbelievable racism but Morris
takes this case he could have argued
that these schools were you know that
Smith school was dramatically unequal we
found that the average white school had
a school library that was worth the
value of about five hundred dollars the
Smith School had a library worth the
value of $3 but Morris didn't argue that
he argued on the principles of equality
and that's important to say that Morris
argued this first before he brings in
another lawyer Charles Sumner but when
they lost the case and the Court of
Common Pleas they appeal
it's the Massachusetts Supreme Court and
a new lawyer got on board there was a
young Brahman lawyer named Charles
Sumner he's more than just a tunnel you
know Charles Sumner was a young man not
much older than Robert Morris but he was
a sophisticated bright man tired of the
law but he knew that there was a
nobility to the law and he still
believed in the possibility that the law
could somehow be used as a tool
to enact change and he was a passionate
abolitionist and so when Benjamin
Roberts and Robert Morris came to him
and said we need your help we are going
before Judge Lemuel Shaw now not a
familiar name but his house is just
around the corner of Mount Vernon Street
and Judge Shaw was described by one
historian that we were researching as a
great warty toad he was an imposing
lioness figure who was very very
imposing to any lawyer who would stand
before him and they knew that they
needed to fashion an argument that could
somehow persuade people that were not
inclined to believe or to unlock the
door for equality together they did
fashion such a case it is hard today to
imagine how you could advance the
arguments passed where they brought them
it is not recorded if Sarah was in the
courtroom that December Day 18-49 when
they walked in Morris and Sumner
together historians feel that they were
the first interracial legal team in
American history and just standing there
before the judge together was a
statement in and of itself of where
America had to go and could go Sumner
emphasized this little child asked at
your hands her personal rights and then
Sunday went on to make statements I
think are very very powerful the
argument took about two hours to deliver
and I don't think we've got that time
tonight but basically I want to make one
or two quick points in a very early
version of the logic that affirmative
action is something that is useful and
needful for our American society Sumner
long ago on that faithful day after
Morris had delivered the facts of the
case Sumner got up and made the
statement that without diversity the
many groups that belonged to a school
quote the whole system of public schools
suffers also this was a very radical
notion he went on to say something even
more radical and it's really the reason
I think that we wrote this book he said
and the italics are ours in the book the
whites themselves are injured by this
separation and who can doubt this can
you imagine what that sounded like in
18-49 that it was the whites who are
themselves being deprived of the full
diversity of our nation and our
possibility as a people and that is most
prophetic he forbiddingly warned the
whole nation he said a degraded and
neglected class if left to themselves
will be left degraded and neglected
segregation had to end or there was a
dark future for all of us and it was
abundantly clear to Sumner that day that
quote prejudice is a child of ignorance
it is sure to prevail where people do
not know each other
I emphasize that again where people do
not know each other well you're probably
not terribly surprised at judge Shaw the
great legal genius basically turned them
down they lost the case in the courts
and in doing so judge Shaw created
something called separate but equal you
may have heard the phrase it was like a
virus that went and I don't answer the
legal system but to every aspect of
American life it is what Thurgood
Marshall and his legal team had to
overturn in 1954 in a long siege that
took them right to the Supreme Court
they had to overturn this precedent the
judge Shaw had created so long ago right
here on Beacon Hill in the Roberts case
it was a hundred year struggle between
two concepts of what Morris and Sumner
called
equality before the law and what Chara
called separate but equal to very
powerful
ideas and which one was gonna win I'd
like to share with you just one more
brief excerpt in May 17 1954 with no
hint of the long-delayed Brown decision
being near reporters told one another it
will be a quiet day in the court instead
at 12:42 p.m. Chief Justice Earl Warren
began to read the momentous decision
opposing counsels Thurgood Marshall and
John W Davis had been warned to be there
and so both were present each confident
that he had made a good case though
Marshall was aware that an error a split
decision for them especially in the
south would be is bad for them as an
outright defeat the faces of the
justices portrayed nothing and neither
did the first 15 minutes of Warren's
reading the Chief Justice proceeded to
set the historical context for the
ruling about to come one that had been
in the making for a century or more
newsrooms across the country were now
alerted waiting for the verdict which
finally became clear when Warren reached
the crucial words the segregation of
children and public schools relies
solely on the basis of race even though
the physical facilities and other
tangible factors may be equal does it
deprive the children of a minority group
of equal educational opportunities we
believe it does Warren had no intention
of revisiting the myriad cases that
upheld separate but equal and there were
many of them but he concluded we cannot
turn the clock back he saw this decision
is based not an old legal principles or
but rather on a new and changing America
however Roberts was one of the few
specific legal cases he cited as he
indicated this had been the birth of the
separate but equal doctrine and so today
we live in an era of resegregate sadly
and tragically
70% of all black children attend a
school where racial minorities are in
fact the majority at their school the
desegregation of black students is now
at its lowest level in three decades
there is no avoiding the truth that we
do indeed live in an era of
re-segregation gary or feel the head of
the Harvard project of school
desegregation says if you really believe
in brown you can't celebrate it right
now but the potential is still there a
contemporary reader might confront these
dismal statistics with despair
concluding that nothing can be done and
if so this fatalism is curious the
assumption would seem to be that
citizens in this generation of free
black living in the backside of Beacon
Hill somehow had more power and agency
than we do today
white and black together the characters
we wrote about in this book
we're not unrealistic about the slow
pace of equality one of the last letters
that the abolitionist William Lloyd
Garrison ever wrote was to Robert Morris
it was in 1879 when the reconstruction
in the south was grinding to a halt the
old warrior acknowledged to his old
friend Robert Morris it is clear for
that the battle for liberty and equality
is to be fought over again but in the
end poorer I believe this is not a
reason to be despondent it is in fact a
call for action
the old man employed Morris once again
for freedom's sake Rock your father's
Hall know the problems faced by Nell and
Roberts and garrison and Morris and
Douglas and Sumner
have not been solved yes American
schools are still obstinately black and
white but it is crucial to remember and
to realize that racism as powerful as it
is is not an unchanging current somehow
frozen into stasis racial separation
still warps and ruins lives but it is
also true that race is a social concept
and therefore it can change and undergo
subtle shifts and alterations right
before our eyes
they hoped and we can do no better and
we have no right to do less in the end
the story of Sara's long walk is more of
a promising gesture to the future than
it is a peon to the Past it is an
unabashed a vocation of certain core
American values in an 1855 celebration
arranged by William now the free blacks
of Boston wisely call their school
desegregation victory quote partial
hopeful and perspective what the
citizens of Beacon Hill did and achieve
before the Civil War is a remarkable
American story in its own way as
impressive as any victory in our history
on the battlefield or triumph at the
ballot box and Paul you'll take us home
yes Stephen give a the e vocation of the
route that this case traveled but one of
the community that lost the case what
what happens Morris now Roberts did not
give up imagine that Robert Morris is a
small man but apparently he was just it
this indefatigable energy and he would
walk into a room and his gestures would
be so large that this energy would just
kind of kind of overwhelmed people and
that was the energy that kept him going
when they lost the case that they kept
boycotting the school that they kept
producing petitions and they gave
petition after petition to the state
legislature I see a great Massachusetts
state legislature here tonight they kept
going they kept going Marty waltz and so
in 1855 the legislature D segregates
Massachusetts schools making Boston the
first major city in American history to
have desegregated schools
lost in the court but they'd won through
Democratic representatives which is even
more of a testament to how hard those
next six years would be but it was the
boycotts the protests the creations of
new outlets for their message and yes
the effective use of white allies as
that battle for open schools went
forward it was a small Beacon Hill
community of fewer than 3000 they've
discovered within themselves the resolve
the determination to force the opening
up think of what they did theaters and
railway cars legalization of interracial
marriage the opening of government jobs
for blacks fighting for memorial of
Boston Massacre Marta Kerr Crispus
Attucks the first formation of an
African American Union regiment to fight
the end of slavery itself when we know
this struggle we can see how long it
takes to define equality how long change
takes to happen but when it's fueled by
the uncommon courage of average men and
women it can so we come back to Sarah in
the midst of a long Smith School
struggle Antebellum Boston the turning
point came and no one really recognized
that at the time but they probably
didn't recognize it either
the Rosa Parks aching feet made her
refuse to sit at the back of the bus
Robert Morris cried out after the
campaign's eventual victory let us be
bold and they will have to yield to us
this is not the story of the famous but
of great things to be achieved by
ordinary people
the genius of boldness and now we love
to have questions and your observations
please
and if you want to come here and give
your name Paul and I will see if we
gonna answer anything
ah
hi my name is Heather Campbell and that
my question is Steve and I understand
that you've written several books before
and I was wondering if there any
particular challenges in handling in
this particular book well there was a
particular challenge in that I never had
a co-author before and and that was a
challenge that made it a lot easier yeah
and and one that I'm related to very
intimately so I never written history
before I discovered that apparently with
footnotes you have to be accurate that
was a that was a big discovery and to
tell you the truth this this was a book
that I was burning to do and Paul and I
really cared a lot about doing the book
I mean that's why we thanked beacon
press at the beginning of this talk you
know it was great to find a press that
believed in it the way we believed in it
and Paul you might want to talk about
the the energy that they made this book
happen well certainly because yeah we
had just gotten more and more fascinated
by the story we'd actually heard about
it first when we were in Memphis of the
National Civil Rights Museum in the old
Lorraine Motel where Martin Luther King
was assassinated and you saw a footnote
about the case and stuck in our mind so
when we were here in Boston we're just
determined to find out more and more
about it and from my perspective you
know I'm a little young to most people's
conceptions of the author but you know I
was just determined to make this happen
I wasn't going to wait till I was 30 or
40 or whenever this was gonna happen now
because the story had to be told the
national relevance is just unbelievable
and people just don't know it we didn't
know it so we wanted to get it out there
and then we were so amazed by just how
rich these characters were that we could
write it like a novel even though it's
all true but the characters just jump
off the page and so I think the
challenge was just having the energy to
research it to the degree where we knew
where folks in this neighborhood got
their hair cut where do they do their
grocery shopping where did the women
gossip where to baba but we know
everything about this because you have
to if you want to tell popular history
with the vividness that we wanted to and
I think that comes across in the final
product
in saying that you have to salute the
historians and the National Park Rangers
who tell this story every single day and
we urge those here tonight and maybe
those watching if you come to Boston get
yourself down to the Shaw Memorial and
meet one of the Rangers and take the
tour of the black heritage of black
Boston it is an amazing experience and
they will tell you this story and what
we tried to do in the book was to add to
their work and to their idealism every
day thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you I have a
question of sort of a follow-up question
to what you were just talking about
about the vividness the authenticity of
the of the vernacular 19th century
ordinary people's experience can you say
about where you went to go immerse
yourselves in that it seems that
newspapers don't report on the
activities of ordinary people history
books aren't written about ordinary
people clipped in the case of what
you're doing right here you know where
did you go what is the raw material of
your history yeah well that was a huge
challenge because I think the reason it
was a footnote is that you know a lot of
historians just want to write about
William Lloyd Garrison and but you know
we knew that there was there was a story
there was a story beyond that that there
was a black led civil rights movement
that happened on Beacon Hill and this
takes a lot of work you know I was I
would go to the Boston Athenaeum every
day you know read the Liberator from
start to finish 35 years every issue and
you know it takes digging and digging
into the context the community we didn't
have you know there weren't all the
letters and diaries that we wished we
could have found you know a lot of these
folks have been lost to history but we
were fortunate to find enough to really
bring them to life we were lucky in that
there actually was a newspaper that did
give the texture of the daily life in
Boston because William Lloyd Garrison
really was very intentional about being
giving a voice to the the black free
blacks of Beacon Hill now unfortunately
when Benjamin Roberts tried to start his
own newspaper twice it didn't work so
there was obviously a problematic aspect
to that but if you read 35 years of The
Liberator as Paul did and I read a lot
of it to the advertisements the articles
does give a great flavor plus the black
abolitionist papers is an amazing
historical project and literally
thousands upon thousands of documents
that have been collected an amazing
resource and and when you have the
resources of the Boston Public Library
and the Massachusetts Historical Society
and the anthon am basically about 95% of
everything we needed to do to tell the
story was right here in Boston and the
the librarians and the historians are
just fantastic people in Boston love
history and even an aspect of their
history that they have made a whole lot
of attention to they were thirsty but to
really delve into it and we're very
appreciative of all the assistance and
help we got to bring this story to life
in the way that we wanted to
hi Stephen Paul Carl Marcie I'm really
struck by the disconnect between the
story you're telling and the passion and
articulation you have right here in this
church and the lack of large-scale
public debate that's going on on a
national level and it seems that one of
the inspiring messages of this book is
activism and I'm wondering if you could
sort of talk about how we can take
lessons away from here to sort of
besides get inspired by these characters
but to really sort of reignite a public
discussion about what you alluded to the
the very real segregation in our society
today mmm oh that's a great great
question
yeah the first is to take that
inspiration to say to ourselves and we
should say for the first 20 years after
desegregation happened in Boston it
actually worked surprisingly well you
know there wasn't kind of conflict we
saw in the 1970s the integration
happened and and residential segregation
took its toll over the decades the fact
of segregation takes its toll in Boston
that's what we have the busing crisis in
the 1970s and that's why we have
separate and unequal schools today in
Massachusetts to be frank about it but
there yeah there are fights and we do we
don't see in our in our national
discourse anymore you know people talk
about equalizing the school but separate
seems to become accepted that that's
just how it's going to be and there are
things that we can be fighting for there
are ideas on the table I mean the first
to me is to preserve permit of action
when you talk about the university level
but but and the educational systems I
mean there are ideas on the table be it
charter schools there well I'm not going
to get into a speech of my views on
education but we need to have that
conversation in our nation about not
just equalizing the schools but why are
we accepting separate why can't we have
our children learn together my sisters
in Boston Public Schools today so
a question that we think about a lot how
can we make these schools in Boston a
lot better I want to address the the
white black angle too but one of the
reasons we want to write this book is
it's it's one of those few fruitful
areas in times in American history where
whites and blacks seem to have found
some way to powerfully and effectively
work together there are too few of those
opportunities in American history as I
said in the talk this is not
particularly sentimental story but it is
an inspirational story it's it's if they
can do it we could do it too I mean
that's why we wanted to write the book
we wanted to convince folks that may in
fact have a sense of despair that in
fact it's possible to do it one of the
things we were talking about earlier was
this lack of political capital and
financial capital that the free blacks
and the North Slope of Beacon Hill had
in the 1850s but when you heard Paul
described the things that they
accomplished they were doing this at the
same time as the federal government was
allowing federal marshals to walk the
streets of Boston to capture people off
the street send them back down south to
be slaves
unbelievable unbelievable pressure upon
this community and they still achieved
it and we say to ourselves we have no
power
we have no agency there's nothing we can
do these are powerful social currents we
can do nothing about that's why we wrote
this book because we're not convinced
that that's true it's an excuse but it's
not true because there are other
opportunities for white and black and
all minorities some seventeen nations
are represented in the boston public
school system today this is no longer an
issue of just white and black boston
we've called ourselves the hub of the
universe for a long time we are an
unbelievable multinational multi racial
city and the people that do the work to
our children know one another they are
the people who hold the future in their
hands and I would hope that this book
could be of some comfort and some
inspiration to them yes it is a book of
history our hope and our trust is it's
an inspiration to the history which is
yet to be written the history that
belongs to our children together thank
you your insight in your research and
your presentation in Sara's long walk
I am the merchant for Asia I'm director
of education with the museum about for
American history and what I wanted to
ask is we are now trying to create an
experience in the abl Smith school for
visitors to see what education might
have looked like what the process might
have been and for those children that
you're talking about from the Boston
Public Schools and other schools coming
through to experience some of what these
children may have gone through in those
classrooms in your research what were
some of the inequities other than what
you cited as the library and the quality
and the money and what were some of the
inequities that existed and the
differences between the school rooms and
the schools that why children were
attending those schools that Sarah had
to pass by coming to the ABL Smith
School and that was my first question
and secondly while we know this case
took a number of years and we know that
William now led a petition for a number
of years to against an and boycotted the
Smith School what kinds of educational
activities were going on in the
community we know about the Adelphi
adelphic Society and other societies the
juvenile garrison Society for self
improvement
what were those kinds of activities that
were happening during this process so
these children didn't get law
first if I went off so talk a little bit
about Paul Ince I'll answer your second
question than you first
well what we found particularly
interesting was the Boy Scout schools
that were set up now before there was
before the Boston School Committee said
we're gonna build a school for black
children you know the black community
had not waited for that they had set up
schools in first in a man named Primus
halls home and so what was interesting
is Oh forty years later after that had
happened and now a large segment of this
community is boycotting the school
because they've come to believe
segregation is fundamentally wrong
they're going back into people's homes
so on
Belknap Street now joy Street there's
the house of John Hilton will pass by
there as we walk up towards beacon yeah
and he set up a boycott school at one
point that his daughter was teaching so
they were saying you know until we have
equal schools you know come come to our
house we'll teach you for now and but
what was amazing is how they kept these
schools going because this was an eleven
year boycott of the Smith School so talk
a little bit about what children would
have experienced at the Smith School a
big reason why this campaign garnered a
lot of momentum initially was was was
the horrors of the Smith School under a
master named Abner Forbes there was a
punishment when a kid would misbehave or
didn't answer wrong he would he had a
habit of whipping the soles of
children's feet what one mom came to
take her child away from the school and
he threatened to throw into the house of
Corrections I mean this guy didn't seem
like a particular savory character but
this is what children were having to
deal with on a daily basis and before
the boycott started it would have been
just densely crowded they pretty much
divided the school into the older
children were on the top
fluor I believe in the air children on
the the lower one and it would have been
overly crowded now after the boycott
starts it becomes almost empty and and
Forbes was replaced by a black
schoolmaster Thomas Paul who was the son
of the great minister of early early
Boston black community and edited he was
a much kinder schoolmaster but but by
that point
the educational experience is kind of
interesting because they're just a
handful of kids in the classroom and
Boston School Committee is saying how
was the sea economically feasible to
keep the school open there no children
we can even teach anymore so I think
that kind of gives up flavours and one
of the reasons we know what the kids
were experiencing is a fortuitous piece
of historical discovery the historian
Louis Brown discovered one of the very
first books written by a black teacher
her name is Susan Paul she was also a
daughter of the great minister Thomas
Paul and she was teaching at the Smith
School and the young boy named James
Jackson died and she wrote a biography
of little James Jackson and in this book
she gives us this unbelievable insight
into what a black school would have been
like and without this we would have been
somewhat lost we know somewhat more
information about Susan Paul because she
often wrote articles and and prepared
musical pieces for the community which
are described in the Liberator including
a song that she wrote for the children
to sing together called mr. prejudice
and and let's hope that our children
never have to sing that song ever again
but that was a Marvis discovery for us
it allows us to get into the school in a
way that seems unbelievably fortunate
any other questions
if not we appreciate your time your
adoption one more francs please
and I just won't point out that the city
of Cambridge next door benefited greatly
from the segregation of the Boston
schools because between 1845 and 1850
black families of Beacon Hill took off
to live in Boston in in Cambridge where
the schools were integrated and the
second thing is that the book there is a
book about Susan Paul I've forgotten the
name of it and the author but it does
that's obviously where are you again it
you might mention if you could you could
remember the name of it I kid Louis
Brown I believe yeah thank you Frank
Frank is the author of groundbreaking
genealogical research into black
families in Boston a real work of love
and care and attention and thank you and
he was very helpful to us in all of our
research as well we thank all those who
are here I see Michael terranova
incredibly dogged and determined local
researcher and Frank and others we
appreciate all the help and the love and
historical attention because history is
not just dead in the past it is not dry
and dusty it forces us to confront our
society together and now the spirit by
which you wrote the book
on behalf of the museum we just like to
thank you all for coming out tonight and
we really do appreciate all of the work
that you put into this story and for
telling the story and for telling it so
passionately we'd like to give you these
hats because it's raining well thank you
very much
leader what can you come forth Leena
represents the Robert's family and we
would love to have a comment from her
first of all I want to just thank you on
behalf of our families but I want to
give a little insight to something
you're wondering how she ended up in the
school and was attending and she was
fear very fair-skinned so she could pass
and that's a story that was just passed
down through the family and it's been
passed down and with and because myself
and several others are here we really
really get into the history and we've
trying to keep it alive ourselves but
she was fear and she was able to attend
the school and it wasn't until her
brother somebody started with her
brother who was a darker complexion and
that's when she was thrown out of the
school and therefore they had her
removed but I want to thank you because
it keeps it alive we have a thing if we
were Roberts you're a really real strong
person and and we're not allowed to be
weak at all and and when you talk about
that I understand just sitting here and
listening to you read that also to think
that her father just fought as hard as
he did and that can you imagine I never
thought about it that way I know we've
thought about it being taken out of a
school how traumatic that would be for a
five-year-old my sister has a father I
can't imagine a five-year-old being
dragged out of a school so that you
can't get a fair education so I want to
thank you for telling that story girls
talk about Hilton Hilton's the other
side of our family so they were very
powerful there's Lennox Charles Lennox
who was also an the 54th so all those
families come together and they're very
strong people and that's who we are and
we hopefully we can continue that but I
want to thank you because you've helped
us also do some more research in our
family history and I thank you for
keeping it alive yes the Robert's family
is looking for Sara's grave site and
it's an amazing story from Robert
Roberts who
one of the first books written by a
black in American history all the way up
to the winning the Medal of Honor for
the Tuskegee Airmen I mean it's an
amazing story and we look forward to you
writing it someday and sharing with all
of us